if you've got a hankering to play a game
set in a galaxy far far away then this
is the video for you young padawan here
are the 10 best star wars games you've
got to play
[Music]
bioware's star wars knights of the old
republic is beloved by star wars fans
and heralded as one of the best if not
the best star wars games ever made set
thousands of years prior to the events
of the phantom menace kotor sees you
exploring the star wars galaxy in an
effort to find a way to stop darth malak
a sith who killed his master darth revan
to take over the sith armada and launch
an invasion against the galactic
republic and a fractured jedi order
along the way you recruit new allies
learn force abilities and make
meaningful choices that influence both
how the story ultimately ends and
whether you embrace the light or dark
side of the force a remake of kotor is
currently in the works at aspire but if
you can't wait until that's out you can
play the original on xbox pc switch and
both android and ios and in the end
as the darkness takes me
i have nothing
totally games star wars tie fighter is a
flight simulator meets space combat game
set in the star wars universe that wowed
fans back in 1994 and i wouldn't be
recommending it if it didn't really hold
up today it begins immediately following
the events of the empire strikes back
and continues until the final battle of
return of the jedi having you play as a
talented tie pilot charged with going
after pirates or traitors to the
galactic empire it's a shame that tie
fighter is no longer canon as it tells a
superb story about what it was like to
be an imperial during the events of the
original star wars trilogy the game
provides insight into the bad guys of
star wars
showing that most imperial soldiers
weren't emperor palpatine level evil
it's a perspective that other star wars
video games like battlefront 2 and
squadrons have tried to replicate but
have never done quite as well as tie
fighter if that sounds up your street
it's available on pc
developer raven software's star wars
jedi knight 2 jedi outcast is the third
game in the jedi knight series which
began with 1995's dark forces the series
follows kyle katan a mercenary turned
jedi who briefly embraces the dark side
and can use all manner of force
abilities in jedi outcast kyle has
forsaken the force only to learn that he
needs to reconnect with his force
sensitivity in order to combat a threat
posed to the new republic jedi outcast
is the point in the jedi knight series
where combat fully transitions to a
hybrid of shooter and lightsaber combat
that along with the really good single
player campaign makes jedi outcast the
best of the jedi knight games it also
sees kyle meet with several popular star
wars characters like luke skywalker and
lando calrissian providing a look at
their lives admittedly a look that is no
longer canon after the events of return
of the jedi jedi outcast is available
for ps4 switch xbox gamecube and pc
bioware austin's star wars the old
republic has come a long way since its
launch in 2011. this mmorpg is still
kicking with a thriving player base and
eight major content expansions taking
place hundreds of years after the events
of star wars knights of the old republic
the old republic allows you to play
through eight distinct storylines during
the ongoing conflict between the sith
empire and galactic republic each
storyline sees you recruiting different
squad mates responding to different
moral based dialogue choices wielding
different weapons and abilities meeting
different characters and having the
chance to fall in love with different
romance options so you basically have
eight different story-driven rpgs here
all of which feature missions you can
tackle alongside well-written npc
companions or real-world players star
wars the old republic is available for
pc
tt games lego star wars the skywalker
saga is a charming and really fun way to
once again experience the star wars
movies lego star wars has certainly
evolved from the original game and lego
star wars the skywalker saga features
cover based shooting multiple hubs that
exist as separate open worlds and huge
star fighter battles fans who know star
wars inside and out can find much to
enjoy in each game including callbacks
easter eggs and characters to play as
galore lego star wars the skywalker saga
is available on pc switch ps4 and 5 xbox
one and xbox series
developer dice's star wars battlefront 2
which is not to be confused with
pandemic studios 2005 game star wars
battlefront 2 made an extremely rough
first impression in 2017. there aren't
that many games that can claim to have a
microtransaction controversy prior to
their official launch on par with this
one but to the credit of dice and
support studios criterion and motive
battlefront 2 got substantial post
launch content balancing updates bug
fixes and most importantly adjustments
to how the in-game economy works it's
now a rewarding game to play with a
decent but not fantastic single-player
campaign about an elite galactic empire
special forces trooper defecting to the
new republic but it does have an
expansive online multiplayer experience
with plenty of awesome modes to play
star wars battlefront 2 is available for
xbox one ps4 and pc
now there are very few moments in star
wars that capture how terrifying darth
vader is the final moments of rogue one
a star wars story his few appearances in
star wars rebels season 2 and his
adventures in kieran gill and star wars
darth vader are certainly the standouts
but that overwhelming sense of fear that
many feel when standing in darth vader's
presence wasn't fully realized within
video games until
vader immortal a star wars vr series you
don't quite realize just how imposingly
tall and intimidating vader is until
he's looming over you and threatening
your life you have acquitted yourself
well
i will not be denied
you will help seize the bright star the
game's story takes place in between
revenge of the sith and rogue one seeing
you play as a smuggler who gets caught
up in darth vader's attempts to bring
padme amidala back to life vader
immortal a star wars vr series is
available for oculus quest oculus rift
and psvr
respawn entertainment star wars jedi
fallen order is an action-adventure game
that incorporates a sakuro shadows die
twice-like parry system for its
lightsaber combat and takes inspiration
from both metroidvania and souls-like
games for its exploration and
progression taking place after revenge
of the sith fallen order sees you play
as jedi padawan turned scrapper
calcastus who goes on the run when
imperial inquisitors start hunting him
fallen order digs deep into some of the
themes only glossed over in other star
wars media such as understanding
yourself enough to fight against your
own darkness and knowing how and when to
ask for help when tackling overwhelming
adversity there's some excellent
storytelling going on when cal meets
night sister merrin and the two try to
broach common ground through the trauma
of watching their respective orders fall
star wars jedi fallen order is available
for xbox series xns xbox one ps5 ps4 pc
and stadia what would jaro te paul say
you have no right to mention his name i
wonder
what would he think if he could see his
padawan now
skulking in the shadows with a betrayer
motif studio's star wars squadrons is
fantastic though the game's
single-player campaign which sees you
alternate between the newest members of
the new republic's vanguard squadron and
the galactic empire's titan squadron
following the events of return of the
jedi isn't very good beyond acting as a
decent story driven tutorial online
multiplayer is a blast to play matches
put you into fast pace 5v5 dogfights
where communicating with your team and
managing how much energy you're putting
towards shields engines or weapons is
just as important as being a good shot
squadrons is simple to learn but rewards
commitment with a high skill ceiling
there are few things as satisfying as
finally mastering an advanced maneuver
and pulling it off at the end of a match
to get the winning kill star wars
squadrons is available for xbox series x
and s xbox one ps4 and pc the ps4 and pc
versions can even be played in vr
lucas arts star wars republic commando
was one of the earliest stories to
explore the identical faces but vastly
different personalities of the soldiers
that make up the galactic republic's
clone army aspire media's enhanced port
is the same excellent game but with
prettier visuals a better control scheme
and no multiplayer though republic
commando's online multiplayer was never
that good to begin with despite being an
older game republic commando first
launched in 2005 it's still wonderful to
get to know the members of delta squad
like boss scorch fixer and sev as the
four take part in three special ops
missions in between the events of attack
of the clones and revenge of the sith
star wars republic commando remastered
is available for ps4 and switch
let me know how you get on with the
games we recommended and make sure to
subscribe for more i'm on twitter at
lucy james games and as always may the
force be with you
[Music]
you